hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing war
yeah why not oops come on why not
eloquence once in a while
it does not hurt what is he doing there
just you for now or something special I
came here recently someone asked about
Bishop f7 and dispositional on reddit
yeah what the hell what is that okay
what's going on in this particular
position just Bishop f5 maybe it's got
night h4 and the movie six something
that I have two that I'm worried about a
little bit okay I'm closing it down
which is not the best move probably but
I want something easy to handle if in
any way possible
so I get this out and I'll get I have to
check should page five point three six
you don't want to see I get a position
that looks a little bit like a little
bit like Cairo advance but it's it's
closed and I don't think this can be too
bad for me
why does better but it's nothing special
there should be three probably keeping
keeping the pawn on d4
okay so I don't want to take at the
moment I rather want to wait until he's
got the night on the tool you know
castling the special age six
so I have to go g6 you know I mean white
the white is a bit more comfortable here
no question huh don't like the pony five
it's my problem opening the French
defenses somehow close to this I tried
the calc on for a while and I really had
to had to stop this simply because I
again got all those positions with E 5
and I just never had a good position
there maybe he cannot take on c5
actually what I'm doing that's very slow
I mean D takes 97 I should get the pawn
back probably but takes Knight back and
something like you know I have to take
absolutely necessary I guess price that
he actually thinks about it
pancakes looks extremely normal
it's a bit odd I'm really happy about
any trade that I can get in yeah the
trades really help because of the lack
of space okay off to g7 it's got c4 I am
too lined up yeah
Queen trade I can actually take and play
Ruby form but Brooke age fry it doesn't
really doesn't really hurt all that much
okay come on
he's good there for five I mean that's
sick
what am I doing here ah what a terrible
decision at least the Queen's are traded
so I have some chances to get a counter
play maybe a little bit of counter play
against e5 a4 is an ordnance
mmm this isn't so bad actually all of a
sudden
when I played that in a bit of a bit of
an odd way okay Kimmy seven yeah I got
95 as well so I'm taking it 93 it's a
bit of annoyance now okay I've got rook
c1 and night be true
we'll win some material but be seven at
the end we'll hang that's a that's a
problem so if I just get the night just
to c6 I will be very okay I'd be 200 I
cannot cover b7 that's a pain
you know I've got a five and deform
under attack
ya know I can actually take takes rook
to Bishop g6 of course as possible but
after going back if five is the next
weakness that I can attack Jim can also
move it but taking cannot be too bad and
now where do I get how do I get to this
let's get to going to before it's okay
it's not deform maybe helpful I don't
probably not
and still tied to all the weak bones so
can I know if activating the king does
help you can also check here it's really
not so quick you might just lose on time
here I just played one or two quick ones
it's clearly better not so it's not a
totally simple win maybe yeah I didn't
like this position somehow yeah I don't
know I don't know about all this here
probably d5 is not right but I don't
know what is right I was thinking this
of course but I thought it six could be
an issue like this is this position I
wasn't sure about it looks a little bit
odd but I have night I have Queen d7
right nothing terrible happens
Queen f3 I've got 95 maybe uh 98 even ah
this is important yeah and then I can
probably send it back later
yeah d5 it's clear that white must be
better after this move but at least it's
reasonably simple to play I didn't want
to allow this this is always awkward
awkward because this is not moving so I
took only three and here I'm always
worse somewhat worse she's six are you
not happy and probably I should take on
d4 after 92 I was really a little bit
concerned that something like that could
be a problem yeah but he cannot open the
position okay yeah it's not so bad I
mean it is worse for me but it is I'm
not like immediately
losing ya age six and now we should
definitely take him yeah I was really
concerned that he would do this him yeah
it's pretty bad yeah I'm just not good
at those positions I'm making mistakes
and give my opponent too much yeah I was
quite happy and that that seems like
playable and he I should of course go on
to e7 just to e7 and I'm okay I wanted
to provoke f4 so that he cannot move the
rook on the fourth rank and here this is
equal if I go to g7 it must be okay yeah
and I just blundered into this it was
really lucky that I was not immediately
losing the the weak pawn on e5 is really
helping me you have a day for is not a
good move I think it cannot be great
great form I know he got c4 c4 has a
problem I have this but it doesn't help
me all that much now that's it's all
week yeah rook e1 look h4 and I'm okay
and now our step by step I get get a
better position on i.t for here was
actually even stronger yeah here still
intended to take on b2 what further
inspection and you see it doesn't really
he's got basically both on the tag and
here I cannot do anything I cannot cover
the pawn so I went night before to
continue yeah Bishop c2 blend at this
now I've got very very clear advantage
yeah I wasn't so sure about d4 Lucas e5
but it's probably strong
I basically just wanted to keep
everything and then see later i rupees
three was a possibility yeah and now I
want on time it is a lot better for me
but it would've still been quite some
work okay guys thanks for watching